welcome to this video playing r2d2 yeah
it feels weird to get to the English
pronunciation when you are so used to do
this in John that's what it's working ok
um yeah that she goin and this is a
somewhat less challenging line I guess f
3 and so on it's more dangerous but I
don't know the ins and outs of that so
I'm going through with a simple simple
line that still filled some like it
should post the the art problem yeah how
do I actually develop this g2 porn here
Bishop d3 can I just yeah maybe come on
thats gambler with that maybe he can
play really something like g5 Bishop g3
and take this no he doesn't so you'll
get a fairly normal looking position
okay so I want I don't want to trade off
like everything immediately may be here
and if he takes on c3 at least enjoy
some sort of center efore may be here I
can go to f4 it's at least a possibility
okay but I want to have some sort of
play him night f4 Bishop c2 asking black
if I e5 might be an annoying threat
night before i'm going to be one i guess
to be one but
not sure Bishop c4 is also very very
valid approach you can take I'm going to
see for that looks a bit more a bit more
active there should be one clocks of my
rook okay yeah I guess with the edge
ponyo yeah there are cases where F takes
make sense they are like the ruckus
sunday open and whatever but it does not
look like this is one of those positions
yeah the night night is a problem peace
do I just kick it back I think I should
yeah as long as so this is this is some
possible I should kick it back he will
play it night b8 possibly what about
yeah I'm not too sure what the right
piece configuration is maybe this and
rook t one nice feature is that 97 s not
maybe he can because of tricks but I
thought that I want to say that it's not
really easy to play okay here I'm going
to smash through this must be the right
solution and then d6 even using using
the power here of the rook and queen
takes takes his poem b6 immediately
under attack now thats that's nice it
should be nice for what let me think
about this though um me how I play this
instantly
yeah it's so that's that sense sudden
you're right yeah I was thinking maybe
it can be possible somewhat you to take
with the rukon d6 but I couldn't really
i didn't i didn't really find any any
way to do that so i guess night coming
to stu's to 2d six would be nice let's
let's try to answer that
I go to f4 here what is your move
attacking the Queen and prepare 96 and
the Queen I mean where exactly is it
going there are some very direct
problems yeah like let's say Queen
somewhere 25 yeah yeah yeah but I have
96 there is a huge problem now or take
first I don't know maybe night 95 is a
move I can take f7 at least and I cannot
really tell let's do this the simple
thing is I can take you and Bishop b5
which should would really wait take
Bishop g5 should be 5 rook c8 Roxy one
box e7 I just barely holds on huh that's
unfortunate time morning at a crook
takes also barely holding ok maybe this
one ah this actually supposition mayor
would need a little bit of time to be
precise
Bishop c4 now i'm not sure i still have
the clearly more active position but i
also only have 29 seconds this will be a
very likely be a pre mufa professed look
coming to the 60 d 7
yeah I have 18 seconds position is just
bad from black but yeah I don't know
maybe he can hold it but it's not much
fun check
rookie to maybe trying to pretend that
it's not playing on time well no I know
we can take that yeah it's stupid I'm
just playing too slow that just just the
simple case check it really makes those
games a bit of a joke because wide
losing is it's just just unthinkable I'm
done playing playing and playing those
so slow that they can play all this
nonsense on time yeah mmm and around
here I mean why isn't this like a direct
wynia and I must be really damn and then
yeah yeah there are multiple interesting
multiple things that are interesting of
course we just go go back briefly Queen
Queen f4 may be instantly as strong I am
true but this is a total record to total
wreck anyway for black so take cake so
and what now what is the most precise
one this is keeping something but yeah
my initial idea was this actually and
then but it does not seem to to be
enough I mean something like that is
young of course better for white but it
takes takes a moves to to to to get this
to something decisive and I have roped
the six this is week and I have the far
better minor piece of course takes a
long time now to win and here yeah I
mean even this is of course better for
wine I mean
this is like a sounds like a broken
record but what was winning Eric's is 68
it's it's enough yeah it's not like it's
it's it's very bad okay here in the rook
endgame black it also goes so I probably
should have gone to the kingside
immediately but it's a moot point I'm on
15 seconds yeah like Here I am a g6 is
of course just bad yeah it weakens f6
let's say let's say just just for fine
let's do an analysis of this position
that black one on time rook ph g form
can just mark time f4 mark time g5 check
yeah like black resign sir this is how
it's it's it's ending if you have a
normal time control but whatever yeah
I'm spending too much time IAM let me
let me think about it yeah it's it's a
typical case of Ted seconds per move not
the super long things sometimes are the
problem but I'm spending too much time
when I have the alternatives like f
various good alternatives and I will win
any endgame probably here just need to
get to it with a decent time clock time
yeah that's that's really not a good
practical attitude okay well thanks for
watching